if you go to Revelation 10 1-6 yep
Revelation 10 1-6 1-6 sir read it me uh
then I uh then I saw another Mighty
angel coming down from heaven the mighty
Angel is Jesus that's Jesus appearing as
the angel of the Lord go ahead um he was
robed in a cloud with a rainbow above
his head his face was like the sun uh
his and his um above his head uh his
face was like the sun and his legs were
like fiery now if you guys don't know
the analogy see this is why John assumes
you know your Hebrew Bible he's just
describing the angel as God and as the
angel of The Exodus why Cloud covering
his head well God appeared in the
cloud rainbow God appears as a rainbow
in Revelation four his face Shone like
the sun right that's the Lord Jesus
Christ in Matthew 17 verse 2 in
Revelation 1116 may the Lord give me P
per recall a very po scripture and then
it says his his legs were fiery pillars
that's the pillar of Fire by
night so he's describing this one as God
the angel of God who is Jesus but keep
going he was holding a little scroll
which lay open in his hand he planted
his right foot on the sea and his left
foot on the land and he gave a shout he
gave a loud shout like a roar of a lion
when he shouted the voices of the seven
Thunders spoke and when the seven uh
tunders when the seven tunders spoke I
was about to write but I Heard a Voice
from Heaven say seal up what the seven
Thunders have said and do not write it
down all the way to six yeah then the
angel uh I had seen standing on the sea
and on the land raised his right hand to
heaven and he swore by him who lives
forever and ever Jesus Lord swore by the
father who lives forever and
ever who created the heavens and the all
that is in them so did he swear by
him yes so but I thought the Lord says
do not swear just say yes and just say
no you see
it yeah now go to Romans 1
ver9 and see Paul swearing by God that
he speaks the truth
Romans 1 verse 9 so guys you see how the
Lord Jesus is swearing by the father in
Revelation 10 because that's the mighty
Angel The Mighty God the angel of the
Lord who is God the one who appeared in
pillar of cloud Pillar of Fire time of
Moses that's Jesus appearing just like
in Revelation appears as the Ancient of
Days the son of man he appears as the
lamb he appears as a li he takes these
various forms and images so that he can
reveal something about his character
nature and His function um Romans 1
verse 9 uh God whom I serve in Spirit uh
in my spirit in preaching the gospel of
his son is my witness wait he swore by
God God is my witness yes okay now guys
if you're listening to this question if
you read Matthew 533 onward start from
33 reading onward about o yes BS no be
no and anything beyond is evil one if
you take it literally that you only say
yes and no and you can never swear by
God then you have Jesus Christ Our Lord
as the angel in Revelation 10 swearing
by God violating his own teaching well
then someone will say well he's not
talking about him he's talking about
human disciples who live in a fallen
World they shouldn't swear okay but then
Paul who's a true servant of the Lord
who had the right hand of Fellowship by
the apostles confirming that the Lord
Jesus appeared to him and confirmed him
as an apostle he's swearing by God do we
have a
contradiction well if we understand the
Lord to speaking to be speaking
literally then we do have attention but
if we understand the Lord speaking
hyperbolically hyperbole exaggerated
form of speech there is no contradiction
so you guys want me to explain to you
what it means if if the Lord was
speaking
hyperbolically hyperbole exaggerated
form of speech I know you want me to
explain that to you right
you want me to explain that to you right
yep please okay why would he be speaking
hyperbole if it's not literal literally
just say yes yes no no never swear by
God that's not what he meant that would
be what we call the plain meaning of the
text that on a surface level that's what
it seems like he's saying but when we
dig deeper and ask the Holy Spirit to
illuminate us to bring out the meat no
the plain reading right the surface
reading is not the literal meaning the
literal meaning is hyperbole meaning
he's exaggerating he's using exaggerated
form of speech you guys with me in the
comment section or you're asleep because
I want you to learn how to interpret
this text how not to interpret it if
he's speaking
hyperbole meaning he's not literally
saying you can't swear by God why then
would he be speaking
hyperbolically because the Lord is
talking about
curing curing your for desperate Wicked
sinful inclinations and struggles what
do I mean just like in Matthew 6 if you
read verses one all the way to seven the
Lord talks about hypocrites and how to
cure yourself of being a
hypocrite Hypocrites and how to cure
yourself from being a hypocrite if
you're a hypocrite and you love
attention and the praise of men so you
pray in front of men so they can praise
you or you fast in front of men so they
can praise you and you know that's what
you're doing and you know this is a sin
that disgust God because you're a
hypocrite then from now on do not pray
publicly and do not let people know your
fasting do it in secret until God cures
your heart so you know your motives are
right is it um so so this ver actually
correlates to the hypocrisy of the
Pharisees then because of all their
shows like like Muslim like the Muslim C
says yeah he Wasing them but he's not
saying that people who pray publicly
they're all Hypocrites that's not what
he's saying because he encourages public
prayer public worship he encourages
fasting together so what is he doing now
let me explain again I hope you're
listening I hope all of you are
listening Holy Spirit correct me on the
spot save me from error perfect my
recall of every jot to the POR scripture
and Empower us to obey it you are the
teacher we trust in you fill us and come
to the forr Forefront for the glory of
the Father the Lord Jesus Almighty and
your glory Holy Spirit In The Name Of
The Lord Jesus Christ I trust in you you
are my teacher our teacher please save
me from error okay so Amen Let Me Go
deeper again the Lord is dealing with
desperate spiritual diseases spiritual
sicknesses what we call sin because sin
is a disease and how to cure those
spiritual sicknesses and diseases so
how do you cure
hypocrisy if you're a hypocrite who does
things for praise and you know it the
way you heal yourself by the grace of
God you don't pray publicly and you
don't let people know you're fasting
until God heals your heart and now when
you pray publicly or fast you know
you're not doing it for pretense putting
on a show that's one
secondly when he says let your yes be
yes or no be no that is a way of
protecting and guarding yourself from
using God's name
flippantly invoking God in your OES when
you have no intention of keeping your
OES and thereby shaming God so he says
if you're a person who has a hard time
keeping your word keeping your promise
the last thing you do is bring God
into the equation and invoke God as your
witness that you're going to do
something when you know you have a hard
time of keeping your word because not
only do you sin but you shame God by
invoking him as a witness for against
you that you're going to keep your oath
so how do you cure
yourself of that social that
spiritual disease wickedness where you
shame the Lord socially because when you
make an oath you're making an oath in
front of people right and and when you
break that oath after invoking God you
dishonor God because people take you at
your word well you're a man of God you
invoke God the last thing you'll do is
break your oath because the last thing
you do is sin against God and shame the
lord well if you know you have a hard
time with that then do not invoke God in
your oathes because you know you have a
hard time keeping your OES keep God out
of it until God heals your heart so that
now you become a man or woman of
Integrity that when you do invoke God
you will honor him by doing what you
promised you would do in his
name you understand yes a third example
third example in Mark 9:43 to 48 or M
Matthew 18 8-9 He says if your eye
causes you to sin pluck it out that's
hyperbole only someone who's stupid
would take that literally because if
Jesus meant to literally then all we
would be is a walking torso we wouldn't
have any eyes we wouldn't have any hands
and feet
if the Lord meant to do it literally so
why is he saying pluck out your eyes
this is hyperbole exaggerated form of
speech meaning take drastic
measures to cut off anything that will
cause you to sin it's not plucking my
eye out but what it is is to cut off any
activity that I know will cause my eyes
to lust cause my hands to sin or where
my feet will
rush into involving myself in a
situation where I'll sin cut those
things off so it's not cutting the eye
off but avoiding and cutting off things
that will cause your eyes to lust in
other words stop watching certain things
stop going to certain places that will
lead you to sin so when it says cut off
your your arm do not put yourself in a
situation where you'll be tempted to use
your hands to sin
or where you'll be tempted to rush with
your feet to sin for example people like
to go to the bar well you got to use
your feet to get there either driving or
walking cut off your feet meeting cut
off any activity that will result in you
sinning people like to go to nightclubs
cut that off that's what it
means
see you understand his point now yes
absolutely is the Lord saying do not
swear by God at all or is he saying
here's the cure to your disease you have
a hard time keeping your word you're
constantly breaking your word and you're
constantly dissing the Lord in order to
avoid God's Wrath stop invoking him just
say yes or no until God cures you